okay so I'm going to talk very very
briefly because in in fact I have so
much material to go over in my head to
sort out that I'm afraid of saying too
much but that in itself I think is a
measure of how for me how successful
this this conference was about which I
was extremely dubious I'm uh I think one
thing that I really want to think about
and that I might have changed my mind on
is I think I'm feeling that the manifest
image in the scientific image is closer
then I used to by way of neuroscience I
saw a I actually feel that things that I
thought there was just no way of
bringing together and yesterday's
discussion about meaning was extremely
useful to me in in changing my my mind
about that
that I actually think there are some
things we can say about generating
meaning intentionality even mattering
perhaps but it was just it was - I'm now
seeing them as somewhat closer and I
then I and I had before but I have to
think through that I'm this thing about
free will my mind was not at all changed
I've been thinking a lot about whether
we should get rid of the word yeah there
for theoretical reason yes I do think so
it would clean things up however it's
very important never to forget that
there's a whole history of discussion
and that what we're saying is a
continuation of that discussion and it
it would be very very important and if
we do decide to change the word not to
say we've dropped the ball you know that
we're we're answering so
questions that have been discussed here
or presenting what to me is a very
coherent answer and so that you know
that there's a certain danger in I mean
in changing the vocabulary there because
the the the continuity of of the
question what else I was a little
disappointed in the discussion of
consciousness just because I would have
liked to hear more I would have liked to
hear more of a connection between our
discussion of the first day in which we
spoke about reduction and explanation
and entailment and what's required for
one level for you know to be reduced
together I would have I wanted that
brought home to consciousness and what
people here had to say about that
whether were there whether or not what
you know how far what you know I would I
really would have planned if there was a
difference of opinion about that I would
have liked to have heard that another
connected with that another subject I
wish we had actually had on the board
was the self that the nature of the self
and Terry you mentioned I think at the
end of the last discussion that none of
this makes sense without the notion of
you know sort of an organism acting
undergoing this and that was sort of a
parenthetically inserted there and I
think that's an extremely important
point and would have liked to have heard
that discussed the other thing was
yeah I've is very interested in the
discussion about our conscious reasons
better than unconscious reasons and Dan
your remarks about you know it's
thinking's a kind of conversation and
there are different speakers that we
have going on there and once you make it
conscious you're making it available to
different Parsi I think that's
for me a very very useful idea and and
it also reminded me of the use of this
kind of thing you know this is because I
mean you know once you I mean we're
putting these things out there for not
just other parts of our minds to hear
but other people who are thinking about
this people from different disciplines
enormous lis enormous ly useful and so I
you know I would just I I wish that this
conversation could continue I wish that
we could not only push naturalism
forward but uh this particular group I
would want to just keep talking to this
particular group about these issues
you